hey guys this is andrew for
traincensus.com so i used to be a
professional trainer for
a bank and i'm right now guys a
professional trader for my personal
account
so it's a new start for me and i'm also
doing some youtube videos for those who
are watching my video for the first time
i started six months ago guys
and i like to use technical analysis and
to update you guys on the favorite
stocks which are for now gamestop and
amc but it can be anything else
and i'm here to share the knowledge that
i acquired during my career
and to show you guys all the tools and
techniques that i like to use to make
money on the markets
so in today's video i want to make a
huge update guys on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys i'm very excited i'm very
excited it's a new start for me
so so i'm gonna keep doing this
daily updates i'm also you know creating
for you guys a big big
course that uh where i'm gonna put all
the information
that i have about trading that i
acquired at work
all the techniques everything you know
so i'm doing this for you guys i think
it's important that some people
you know share this knowledge you know
from the professional industry
to the retail investors so i'm here for
this
and i'm gonna show you guys what i can
do with it
on amc so in my last video i was
showing you my different scenarios so
let me just remind you quickly what is
happening here
so my preferred scenario is this one so
i'm gonna keep this one
here we are having here a triangle guys
all right we are having here a triangle
so let me just show you once again what
are triangles so here
one two three four five
this one let me put it in yellow all
right
okay we're having a triangle here and
look what is said about triangles so
this is the iliad wave
course this is my bible guys it's
where i learned most of what i'm doing
here idiot wave basically is the last
step
guys to do you know training based on
charts you need to
understand all the other techniques you
know the basics are trend lines moving
averages
and then you go step by step you start
to use fibs
with retracements projections then you
start to combine it with indicators such
as rsi or macd to find divergences
and finally guys you associate all of
this with this theory
so everything i said before is not in
this book but everything i said before
is what i'm showing you guys in all my
videos
and when you associate all of this
together you come up with the kind of
analysis that i'm making and guys
for those who are following my videos
for sometimes you know that it's working
well
it's working well it's giving me good
targets this is how i found
that we're gonna go to 35 first then
rejected 26
exactly the way it happened here then we
went to 65 75
this was as well an area i found with
fib extensions
and right now yes we're having this
triangle so this is what i wanted to
show you i showed you this already in my
last video but it's good to see things
a few times guys because remember this
triangles
nearly always all right as far as i'm
concerned i would say always you know
the knowledge here
is like you know i don't know i've
almost never seen a triangle in the last
position of an impulse but always occur
in positions prior to the final
actionary wave in the pattern of one
larger degree wave
so for example in an impulse all right
so
this is what we are having here one two
three four so we gonna have five guys
we're gonna have a five
i almost can guarantee it all right i
mean idiot can guarantee it i'm just the
one that is speaking for him because
eliot
is dead guys he was a very famous
investor
in the 1930s and he did amazing
things he won a competition of life
training
where he just beated all his competitors
by far he met
for around 400 percent in a matter of
month on the market with real money and
from there he explained
everything in his book that has been
since then rewritten
by preston frost and this is what i'm
having here so this is guys
amazing information and i sum it up for
you guys on the link in the description
of this video so just click on it
and you're gonna see guys how i do these
things
anyway so here we going to 135
i think and let me show you a bit uh
with a step back
how this is looking guys i mean this is
nothing that's incredible guys if you go
on a weekly time frame you see we were
training at 35 and 2016 guys so i know
here there was the covey guys
but you know there was so much money
printed uh now there is so much
bullish momentum in the stock that going
235
is nothing guys that is that crazy for
me
you know it's just a bullish stock that
is doing well
uh with investors that believe in the
company and for me this is
all good you know this is all good and i
can even see
some more moves up guys i really don't
think we're gonna trade below
35 but once again one of my scenarios we
go to 25
and then we strongly bounce back i think
the stock is going very very well guys
don't listen to analysts they have
always been wrong guys remember on tesla
analysts were saying when tesla was at
300 that it's overvalued
now tesla you know it went to 3 000 and
and yet
you know from 300 to 3000 times 10 and
then divided by five there was a split
so now it's putting around 600 so it's
like old
3 000 and analysts have been wrong the
whole way and they are wrong here again
so let me show you guys my ultimate
scenario this is one
okay i have one here and don't be scared
guys don't be scared
i have one here too
all right so don't focus on those levels
i'm not here to
you know just give stupid high levels
i'm just here to do what i know how to
do which is
uh use iliad to analyze moves up so i'm
just telling you guys
that i have a few more fifth wave to
come of course
at a certain time the price action would
be so high
that it's gonna be tough for a stock
like amc to keep going higher but i'm
just saying
that we have plenty of room on the
upside and that this move
here 235 that many people consider like
crazy is not crazy at all for me when i
look at the charts guys once again you
saw how it was looking on the weekly
timeframe
with a step back it's not crazy levels i
mean you want to look at tesla charts
this is crazy
and this is holding and this is going
much higher by the way
i mean it's so good for me so this is
what i wanted to show you guys and i
want to show you some cool option
strategies as well
here guys all right let's go here yahoo
finance where i get all the information
this is a very
nice database guys let's take some
options
and let's check what cool option
strategies because guys the fifth wave
is coming it's probably going to come
before june so let's go into june
maturity
let's see what we can do here guys so as
usual i copy paste
copy paste this
i put this information here guys this is
the average
otherwise you might have some weird
numbers all right
okay guys let's see it's 450
that's insane totally insane
all right guys 460 so here
guys the best for me option strategy
that we can make here is the one that is
here guys
you know once again i'm going to show
you the different steps that you can
make
you can buy for example a 70 strike code
all right because you think
like yeah yeah she can go 200 but if amc
goes
so my scenario is amc goes to 135
so here you make 5 000 us dollars if amc
goes
okay 6 thousand u.s dollars if amc goes
to 135
which is beautiful guys all right so
this is actually a nice strategy as well
but you can make better than this so you
can then
sell for example 235 how much is it
depending on how much it costs
you see it cost guys you know it costs
100 u.s dollars
all right so for 200 us dollars you can
make a very nice strategy like this
you start to make money above 17
but guys if we break the triangle on the
upside we gonna go much higher
so this is a nice strategy you can make
the strategy i would make
i would go to the higher strikes i would
buy the 100
i would cap it here and i would spend
more
okay so now for 290 dollars
if my scenario happens it can go to 15
000 us dollars so just look at this guys
in terms of performance this divided
by this okay times 60 guys all right so
this is the kind of cool strategy you
can make once again
remember that those very high volatility
strikes you want to sell it you don't
want to buy it so that's why i buy here
i sell higher
all right this is what i learned at work
to sell those high volatility strikes
so this is a strategy you can make
another thing you can make guys if we go
for example if you have shares
and we go to very high levels you can
just consider
capping your performance capping your p
l all right so just sell
one call option with a hundred
multiplier so it's hundred shares
equivalent uh when amc goes to 135
if you are long shares don't hesitate
guys to sell
this cool options if you don't want to
sell your shares so it's you're just
capping your performance this is a very
smart move because you
take advantage of of this very high
volatility
that you can find here 450 guys it's a
lot
all right it's a lot in terms of daily
move you just divide by 16.
so it's 28 a day which is fair but it's
the kind of cool strategies that you
guys can make
and keep in mind that you're probably
going to develop higher soon and that
there is a lot of gamma
on this dune maturity so i know you guys
heard many times
that on the expiry days stocks can move
a lot but guys this is true
especially when you have that many
options look at this guys
8 million equivalent shares on the 145
strike coming from the june maturity
this is something that can blow up some
market makers that are going to be
forced to buy at crazy level
this can create a squeeze gamma squeeze
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys